le prestigieux trophée lancôme c'est
jusqu'à demain soir sur le golf de saint
nom la bretèche dans les yvelines à
cette occasion nous avons dressé un
bilan sur le golf en ile de france il ya
80 mille licenciés mais les additions
sont au point mort
pour les franciliens le golf reste un
sport d'élite et ce n'est pas toujours
qu'une image le reportage de philippe
panis et christian bale terre bonjour je
vous téléphone je voudrais connaître les
conditions pour devenir membre du golf
de joyenval s'il vous plaît le golf de
joyenval près de chambourcy c'est l'un
des 35 golf privé très privées de la
région parisienne pour accéder à leur
parcours de conditions la patience les
listes d'attentes sont longues et bien
sûr beaucoup d'argent si j'ai un souhait
à formuler c'est que les golfs 5 étoiles
s'arrête et que l'on vienne construire
le plus rapidement possible des épaules
chf 2 étoiles plus accessible à la
majorité des 80 mio chf eur
d'ile-de-france les golfs dit ouvert au
nombre de douze capitaux privés mais
parcours ouverts au public une journée y
coûte de 200 à 300 francs enfin au bas
de l'échelle des tarifs nous trouvons 14
golf public moins sophistiqués - classe
dirait certains mais plus abordable
je crois qu'il faut détruire un certain
nombre de clichés qui polluent le monde
du golf en france
bien sûr il ya des golfs fermé des golf
public comme celui ci permettent à des
joueurs en semaine de jeu pour moins de
100 francs
je dirais très exactement 87 francs 50
l'accès à la première partie du parcours
licence équipements et accès une fois
par semaine un parcours public le budget
golf annuel de débutants est estimé à
6000 francs à moins bien sûr de céder à
la passion ça me coûte pas mal d'argent
parce que j'ai essayé d'atteindre un
très bon niveau amateur et donc je passe
tous mes loisirs affaires du golfe
donc c'est vrai que je dépense pas mal
d'argent messi joue un tennis à haut
niveau avec les stages avec les
déplacements etc
ça me coûtera autant d'argent avec huit
joueurs pour 1000 habitants
vingt fois moins qu'au canada l'île de
france n'est pas encore une terre de
gaulle se force ou pour des son image
élitiste
la forte proportion de parcours privé
n'y est pas étrangère et contribuent à
répandre l'idée selon laquelle le golfe
pour un pratiquant ces dix neuf trous 18
pour journée et un trou financier